Hello, everybody.
Welcome to the webinar today.
My name is Peter Cooper.
This is a short webinar.
We may not have time to address questions.
If you think of any, please type them in the
question pod.
We will answer them in a document and post
on the webinar and courses page after the
webinar.
There is a link to the directory on the FTP
site that has these slides, as well as the
other materials that I will be talking about
today.
Also the recording will be in there once we
process it, as well.
Today we will talk about downloading genome
data.
In particular, I will talk about sequences
and the corresponding annotation files from
the NCBI FTP site.
My email address is on the slide; peter.cooper@nih.gov.
If you have any questions about the content
feel free to write to me.
We will talk about more content at the end.
Today I will talk about these topics.
Quickly with some slides.
Then we will go over to the command line and
show you some, we will use both web pages
in the command line to download genome sequences.
We will talk about Assembly, which is the
main way of organizing the genome sequence
data.
I will talk about what I will call the new
genome FTP site.
It's been there a couple of years but a lot
of people don't know about it.
We will go over some recommendations for downloading
assemblies.
We will show you how to do it.
I will mention the Genomes announce email
list which has been restarted recently.
It will be a good way to find out about things
changing about the genome site.
And like I said we will do some quick demos.
Just a terminology thing, today when I am
talking about genome sequences I will be calling
them assemblies.
Those are the things we will be downloading,
the sequences that are models of a genome.
The genome itself is an abstract concept in
a way.
It's an idealized concept in that it's something
that exists in an individual person or organism.
What we will download today are assemblies
of genomes or representations of genomes.
That's why the resource we will be using is
called Assembly.
This is what the web resource looks like.
It's an Entrez database that we call them.
It is the way basically of finding out about
what sequences are available, the genome sequence,
for a particular organisms.
And even meta genomes.
It tells you about the assembly structure.
we now have accession numbers for assemblies,
GCA for our GenBank assemblies and GCF for
the RefSeqs.
This is the way to track the relationshp between
GEnBank and RefSeq, and it's the basis for
the FTP site, which we will talk about extensively.
Notice that I have circled on the page, this
picture of a page really, this download to
the genome FAQ.
A lot of what I will tell you today is based
on the FAQ.
I did not write it, Paul Kitts did, but it
is very useful.
To get you started on how to do these things
at NCBI.
If we look at a page.
This is the one for the human assembly, the
name is GRCh38 patch eight.
You can download either the GenBank or RefSeq
versions by following these links.
I will not go over the contents of the Assembly
page because we will mainly talk about the
FTP site and how to get the data out of there.
If you go to the FTP site, and the base URL
is ftp.ncbinlm.nih.gov, and I will show you
that in a minute.
There are three main directories.
There is a genomes/all/ directory and that's
where we will point a lot of our URL paths.
You cannot browse this currently, if you try
to open it up in your web browser it would
fall over.
There are more than 45,000 directories in
there.
I will talk about the fact that we will restructure
that soon and it will be easier to deal with.
If you are targeting specific files and directories
and you have a path, then there is no problem.
You don't want to open it in your web browser.
The two directories that are browsable are
the genomes/genbank and the genomes/refseq.
They support browsing and downloading for
higher level taxonomic groups, or you can
drill your way down to the species level and
we will do a little of that today.
If you go into the FTP directories here, the
genomes/genbank directory on the left and
the genomes/refseq on the right.
You can see the organization by taxonomic
groups; organisms really, not necessarily
taxonomic groups.
You'll then see the assembly summary text
files.
These are the files you would go to get the
paths to download data.
You can certainly see examples of that on
that genomes download FAQ.
Today I will show you how to get to them using
EDirect, which is basically the same thing.
In fact the assembly summary file is one of
the most useful things.
There is this column 20 thing.
And that has the FTP path.
You can also get that using EDirect.
If you look at the directory for a particular
assembly, you can see them like this.
On the left is a prokaryotic assembly that
is for the staph aureus reference genome.
The one on the right is for the human reference
genome.
There are lots of different files in there.
They are sequence files; there are annotation
files which include things like the gff file.
I will not go over what the files are today.
It's not the point of this particular discussion.
But the descriptions are included in that
genomes download FAQ.
There is also a Readme on the FTP site which
describes the content.
I wanted to mention to you that - - I mentioned
this in passing a minute ago.
We will be changing the way the structure
of the genomes/all directory looks.
In principle, the things I am showing you
today will not be affected by the change at
all.
Basically what you will be doing is getting
the path to the directory and they will simply
change, but you will still be getting the
path.
Doesn't really matter.
Just to show you what will happen is we will
make these hierarchy directories so you can
browse them.
And the directory structure will be based
on the assembly accession number.
And every three digits will represent another
level in that directory tree to make it possible
to browse it.
As I said it will not affect the workflows
we will be talking about today.
You can still browse the genomes/genbannk
or the genomes/refseq directories and you
can use the text files and EDirect to get
the new URLs.
Notice that the directories are named by the
accession dot version of the assembly and
the assembly name.
That will not change either.
So how do you get data out of the FTP site?
For a few assemblies, a small number, you
can use Entrez.
For batches you can use E direct or the assembly
summary text files.
You can download directories from the genomes/genbank
or the genomes/refseq directories on the FTP
site.
I'll show you how to do that.
I will show you a couple of commandline programs
which are pretty good ways of doing this on
a Unix system.
You can use wget on Windows as well.
One way to get things down is to use the NCBI
rsync server.
It's probably one of the fastest ways of doing
this.
I will demonstrate that today.
You could also use wget with these ftp paths,
or curl if you want to, to download the files
in the directory.
If you have to download a large number of
files you can write a simple script that calls
rsync or wget to do this.
There is a sample Perl script in the materials
directory for this particular talk, and you
can see that if you go to that directory on
the FTP site.
The code for that Perl script is included
on the file.
Lets go to the command line and do a few things.
Let's work with getting fungal assemblies,
and I'll show you how to use rsync to download
data and show you how to use wget to download
directories and files.
I will go out of this and I will pull up a
command prompt.
You should be seeing a command prompt here
on one of the servers at NCBI.
What I will do is on the FTP site there is
a list of commands that we will be going through
which is basically the demo.
One of the first things I want to do is use
the assembly resource to get a particular
path to a genome.
This is an Entrez query.
You can write this yourself or get it by using
the filter options on the assembly resource.
I will go into another tab over here and go
to the NCBI homepage, go to Assembly.
I have some filters on and I will turn them
off.
This is the assembly homepage.
This by the way at the bottom is the link
to the FAQ which will be important if you
want to do these things.
I will go ahead and paste this query in.
So I have six of the complete fungal genomes
here.
You can see them.
What I want to do is get you to the path to
download one of these genomes.
This is the one we will download.
This is the Saccharomyces cerevisae, the yeast
reference genome.
If I click here it takes me to the assembly
record.
There are lots of things here we don't have
time to talk about.
Notice you can see the assembly accession
number for the RefSeq.
You also can see the GenBank referenced here.
We can go to the RefSeq assembly page here
to download this, and we can see the URL that
goes into the genome/all a specific directory
for the assembly accession and then the the
underscore character.
So with an ftp client or even a web browser,
you can download files individually, but let
me show you that you can do this easily using
rsync.
I will show you command lines for a few minutes.
I will not explain everything.
If you want to know what the options are you
can look at the man pages for the different
programs, the man page for rsync and the man
page for wget when we get there.
Let's do a rsync command to download all of
this data that's in there.
That will be the sequence file and annotation
files plus, this directory here, which contains
more files, which are chromosome by chromosome
and information about how the assembly was
put together.
I am going to go back to my script here.
This is the rsync command we will do to get
this down.
I pulled the trigger pretty fast on that one,
so let me go back up here because I wanted
to mention a couple things.
This is the basic command.
These things have to do with whether we are
going to keep symbolic links and turn them
into the files.
Recursive means we will go down the directory
tree structure.
This is essentially the URL to the FTP site,
the protocols is replaced with rsync.
That's what you do.
And then I just told it to put this in a directory
called yeast.
And it tells me the information from the server.
It downloaded all of that stuff.
Including the directory structure to my hard
drive.
And there is the yeast directory.
And there are all the files that were present
on the site.
While we are here let me show you something
else.
Another kind of download that we might want
to do.
so we're in genomes/all, but what if we want
to get all of the fungi reference sequences.
What I can do is change this genomes/all directory
and I will do this by hand.
Now I am looking at the genomes/refseq directory
which contains the different organism groups.
I can download for example suppose I want
to download all of the fungal genomes here.
Or all of them in fact if I wanted to.
I could write a rsync command to do that easily.
This is the one I want to use and we will
discuss this one a little bit.
What this one will do is it will go through
here and avoid a lot of the directories in
there.
Basically it will get rid of the assembly
structure directory and get rid of the latest
assembly versions.
And it will get me the protein FASTA file
from each one of these.
This is a rather long complex rsync command
line.
You look at the options yourself and you can
see what they do.
Let's try to run this one.
What it will do for us is it will give us
all of the protein files.
This one will take about 15 seconds or so.
If you notice what happens is it's reproducing
the directory structure tree that is present
in NCBI.
This is basically mirroring the data, but
it is getting a specific file from each directory.
We will get the protein files from each one
of these fungal genomes.
We can see they are there.
If we want to we can go into the saccchromyces
directory.
So we have the reference genome directory,
which is retained from the NCBI side.
Also this one.
This is the assembly accession.
You can do some things to make it so you did
not get all of these directories if you did
not want them.
There is the protein file.
Those are the files of all the proteins that
were annotated on that particular genome.
Now there are some other examples in here
using rsync and you can take a look at them.
I want to move onto the next way of doing
things, which is to try to use wget, and you
can also use rsync to do the things as well.
This is a strategy of trying to get the FTP
paths.
Either from the assembly_summary.txt file
or to get them from EDirect.
I will use EDirect and we have a webinar on
that if you need more information.
I will use that to get the paths.
This is my EDirect command and it will use
the same query we used in the assembly resource.
Then I will use efetch to get the document
summary, which has a section that has the
FTP file paths in it.
I will get out the RefSeq FTP directories
out of that.
Let's try that and see how it works.
Only thing I have added to this is there is
a little sed command at the end that will
add that forward slash directory symbol to
make them directories, which will make them
work better with wget.
That file contains URLs that would take me
directly to those directories and I can potentially
download those exactly the same way I did
before.
I could use a different way to do that if
I want to.
And the way I was going to show you was to
use wget.
What this will do is give you the same kind
of information I got for the yeast for all
of those complete genomes.
This is a taller order, maybe not, than the
one we did a minute ago.
And the different options here are ways of
dealing with the kinds of default directors
that wget will put on your machine.
You can organize those in different ways by
choosing how many directories cut, and so
on and so forth.
Again I refer you to the wget man page.
I will put it into a directory called complete
fungal.
So I now I have directories for all of the
different, the six complete genomes we saw
a minute ago using the assembly resource.
For example I went into the yeast directory
here.
What I did, one of the switches I added - - I
did not get the semi-redundant, the assembly_structure
directory, I did not get that.
If I wanted to I could've done it by changing
the level.
I have a level one here which means I won't
descend, but I could've descended into the
next level.
The last example which I will not do today
goes ahead and gets a particular file out
of each of these directories.
You can do that with wget.
You can also do that with the Perl script
included in the directory for the materials
for this particular FTP site.
All of that stuff including additional examples
are in that text file on the FTP site.
Before I conclude, let me go ahead and throw
up another slide which has information about
staing current and also just to remind you
of something I said earlier.
The mailman list or the email list for genome
announce has been revived.
It has been dead for a while but it will provide
you with information about changes in the
genomes area of the FTP site, for example
the kind of change I was talking about with
the genomes/all directory.
The genome download FAQ document is there.
Again when I have these abbreviations like
NCBI in angle brackets, that just means the
URL [www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov] goes there.
Likewise in the FTP in angle brackets it means
the URL for the NCBI FTP site goes there.
I also want to remind you that we have in
NCBI help manual that is listed there and
has good instructions about how to use EDirect.
There are a bunch of very useful factsheets
there.
And there is one which gives you the same
information we did today.
There's a link to the help desk or you can
write to me and my email address is given
to you at the beginning.
It is pretty easy it is just my name, peter.cooper@nih.gov.
If you have questions about the webinars,
or when will we do a webinar on this that
or the other, when will the files be ready?
Those kind of things, send that to webinars@ncbi.
I will go ahead and conclude there.
I think we can hang around for about five
minutes or so if there are any questions that
are general.
There don't seem to be any.
If you have questions, you can write them
in the questions pod.
We'll make a document that has any questions
and answers that came in during the talk and
put it up on the FTP site.
I guess we will wrap it up.
Thank you all for coming.
And we will talk to you next time.